Tuesday morning was a very exciting morning over at our house.
Tuesday was the day that our dairy cows got delivered.
So we all got dressed, hopped in the can am
and made over the dairy just in time for the cow truck to arrive.
So we had. I invited the bars over to documents.
We had neighbors over. We had Aiden and Glenn and Corrine and Stockton.
All hands on deck.
I walked into the barn right before the cows came in and just like
got super emotional. I mean,
this project has been.
We've been dreaming about this since the beginning of our marriage.
And um, the barn has been under construction for about two years.
And so to see it all ready to go and ready for cows was just like
such an amazing feeling. So the cow trailer,
it backed up, it got into the loading unloading dock.
I guess you could say that we put up
and then we just watch them unload all the cows.
So we have a mixture of Jersey cows and Jersey Holstein cross.
So that's why you'll see some variation in the cows.
But like, we watched every single cow get off the.
The truck. This is a double decker truck.
And so after the, the bottom, um,
tier was empty, they opened up the,
the top tier and we watched the cows come down from there,
which is really cool.
We had all the. The boys had friends over,
And neighbors were coming over to see.
This is like, such an exciting day over at the farm.
Um, a lot of anticipation for this event.
These are the robot installers.
So these guys have been working on the barn since day one
with us as well. This is an all robotic dairy,
A Lele robotic dairy.
The Lele robot is made in Holland. That was made honey
designed in Holland.
Make them in America now as well.
But, um,
yeah, it's been a really cool process
to get all the aspects of this barn ready to go for cows.
And just seeing them walk in for the first time was so exciting.
Everyone just kinda watch the cows for the first couple hours,
get situated.
Um,
Martha was trying to pet them from the get go.
She was like, she's gonna win them over.
That's her goal. So we started right off the bat
getting their robotic collars on.
So this is what Stockton's doing over here.
He's putting their collars on so they can go into the robot.
So this is Glenn, um,
with the first cow. She'd walked into the robot.
And we're kind of on the backside of the robot,
is what we call it.
And this robot goes underneath the udder,
washes it, and milks her out.
And then it shows us, you know,
how much eat teeth each teeth is giving, um,
how much she's weighing, how much she typically gives.
It takes her Temperature. Um,
it's really like an incredible machine.
I'm excited to show you more as we get going on these robots.
But it is a learning curve for the cows
because they're not used to robotic system.
So that's what we're going to be doing for the next two weeks,
is training these cows to the robot.
Of course, for Joe,
with all this milk talk, was.
Was hungry. We spent the whole day at the dairy just watching cows,
learning cows, getting them milked in the robot,
and, um, yeah,
learning about. Learning about each one of them.
The kids named every single one of them,
so that was. That was a big job.
We're definitely gonna have to rename a lot of them, because, um,
I think most of the kids were hungry when they did the naming process.
So a lot of them are, uh,
food items. So I'll probably have to rename some of the cows.
But it was just, uh,
so fun to just spend the day in the dairy, learning,
seeing, um.
Yeah, watching the barn come to life is actually quite an emotional day,
too, for Daniel.
And I, like,
I'd catch him in the corner just,
you know, tearing up.
He's like, can't believe this is happening.
You know, a lot of,
a lot of hard work to get to this point.
Here is Mabel. She was Karen's right hand girl in getting all the cows.
Their collars on and numbered for Lunch,
we had. We came home and had milk.
Cause that's what we. That's what we're gonna eat now.
Three meals a day, you know, that's what we got.